ces petits moments de bonheur cette
famille les a durement gagnés ces
demandeurs d'asile ont effectué 1 re de
voyage de trois mois en bateau et à pied
pour fuir la violence dans leur pays
leur arrivée au canada leur pays de rêve
comme il l'appelait a été brutal donc
des enfants moi je ne voulais pas
laisser mes enfants imaginent doit se
plonger plus rude jean un nom fictif a
été détenu au centre de surveillance de
l'immigration à laval faute de papiers
d'identité
son garçon de 4 ans et sa fille de deux
ans lui ont été retirés par l' agence
des services frontaliers est envoyé dans
deux familles d'accueil différente
les enfants ne veulent pas le plus vu sa
conjointe était arrivé au canada 10
jours auparavant en sainte anne avait
été séparée de son mari et de ses
enfants durant leur long voyage
'l'annonce tant espéré de leur arrivée à
montréal a vite viré au cauchemar
votre mari est ici et il est à la
détention et vos enfants sont dans des
familles d'accueil
waouh c'est comme si les la terre se
fonderait et quoi dit non pas mes
enfants
non non non non et s'il vous plaît
rendez moi mes enfants
ces événements se sont produits en 2018
pourtant une directive nationale adoptée
l'année d'avant stipule que l' agence
des services frontaliers ne doit pas
séparer les familles sauf dans des cas
extrêmement rare en a compté 182 enfants
dans l'année 2010 9 des nuls l'organisme
action réfugiés montréal a commencé à
faire le compte quand il s'est aperçu
que la nouvelle directive n'était pas
toujours appliquée on a eu quelques cas
en 2018 qui nous ont quand même choqué
de voir des enfants séparés vraiment
brute semaine voire plus longue
un an et ses enfants ont été rapidement
réunies mais son mari est resté en
détention durant près d'un mois et elle
a accouché seule de leur troisième
enfant
on a commencé notre vie ici avec une
peur bleue dans le ventre quoi oui
vraiment une peur bleue au bureau du
ministre de la sécurité publique bndes
mais un responsable de l'agencé des
services frontaliers on affirme que le
bien-être des enfants est la priorité
absolue
mais on ne dit pas pourquoi autant
d'enfants ont été séparés de leurs
parents
l'année dernière ici bréger bureau radio
canada ottawa